hello and welcome to our Monday Night
Live show yes some are my setup is it
was a little bit stranger I started my
broadcasting software and somehow it
lost all the things that are said last
week I know oh that happened anyway it
looks a little bit different I have to
really check this while having a bit
more time on my hands I set this up like
a couple of minutes before the show it
is just it is just a little bit
different than it usually is but I think
it will work out so let's not worry too
much
I'm going to request a five-minute game
and check this after the show also
there's no green screen up so you have a
good look at at the books behind me
let's see the first game playing van
impe er okay I'm going Knight f3 against
him a little bit surprised that he's got
the Belgium's like this and I am from
Germany usually okay let's go back to an
evil position and yeah this is not a
particularly great line that he plays
but you always place that and I don't
understand why Knight is six yeah I
think you just you just take isn't that
very weird even Bishop d2 and then
Bishop c3 looks good
I mean black is upon upon down in this
position does he really have does he
really have a good position here hmm if
I go if I just go e5
don't quite get it
it's going to eat four more this is
enough for the porn really is attacking
c5 yeah I should pay attention it still
looks a bit strange we'll see maybe he
can regain the pawn technically but the
development is not great blacks
development yeah he's a head on the
clock I agree on that
okay so this way okay now let me take
this and develop I guess what we need to
to immediately trade yeah why not
I need you I mean I cannot castle with
the Queen on a six so let's do this
[Music]
yeah does black have compensation yeah
it's a good question I really don't
believe it so I can take care right it's
their tactic that I'm missing no I can
just take really are you serious okay so
he gets his back which in the process I
get my um my pieces developed okay night
out now probably look at the age yeah or
this one
oh I don't really I don't really believe
it still let's see how do I get my rook
into the game probably via a three
so yeah let's do here even I teach was
not a concern I think
okay might as well prevented
96 to f4 wired could be an idea if I go
here though what is he doing yes that
she Corinne okay for black you mean the
she go in defense to the Queen's Gambit
or is there are a couple of chickens out
there I mean that that opening cannot be
completely bad but it is certainly not
easy to handle I think it's interesting
though the chil'ren defense to the
Queen's Gambit it's one of the very few
defenses against g4 where you've got
real peace play going for you and you
don't have this all that walking in d4
openings especially if it's something
with not such a higher theoretical
workload let's say another defense that
would have good peace plays Grune felt
but playing the goon felt is really
really tough from the theoretical point
of view okay it's given me a couple of
points which is nice oh it's nice if
they are generous and give you pawns
maybe is giving me even more
and now 95 or what are we doing here 95
nano is this is also hanging on f6 so
how do we win this position there should
be a win Knight cannot move I can also
give a check but what is this next move
maybe I should just do this intend
ignite c4
maybe it takes g2 here right still still
still tough for him to move
got him completely tied down you on that
noida 595
we had sets the exchange and all in all
it's a bit too much okay so I just take
it here it should be the easiest way to
win
Oh what is the quickest way to do this I
probably just push this forward cannot
take this anyway hmm if that was a
little bit it was a little bit loose
what I did here I could have done that a
little bit a little bit easier way it's
still completely winning but it was
quite unnecessary
I'm promoting the h-bomb that was a
little bit a little bit weird play in
the end but it was not spoiled at anyway
any point yeah I don't know he always
plays this opening which i think is just
incorrect okay let's get a new game
going I have a new challenge out okay
what is my rating here to 380 something
and see if we can get above 2,400 that
would be good yeah I don't know
I started the software and I had to set
it up last week and somehow it lost all
the settings which was quite weird I had
to build up everything new yeah and in
the xsplit software and really really
strange okay let's go play King Lear
somebody mentioned that she current
defense to the Queen's Gambit yeah I
have no real idea about it but let's
let's do it I know that this is a line
it looks extremely funky at that plate
somebody played this against me quite a
bit I'm not really sure who that was
then chromis chromis I think what's the
name see the master I think so yep let's
develop okay I have to go back Jim what
what is that is that a decent position
or am I just a bit worse maybe I am a
bit worse
okay so he goes to see forum not much to
do about that is he going to go fo on
it's possible so maybe I should give
some more protection to a for someone
god no I cannot allow the doubling of
the pawns okay I can go h6 and and back
to let's do this
it's f5 moving this pollution or not
yeah
I think I need to I need to need to get
some concrete play going and I mean this
is somewhat active mm-hmm I have some
decent pieces him but white seems to be
better
also I'm not quite sure if he just okay
what is the point
but should F to maim him yeah I will
just I will just fire up let the bishop
on d6 a gadgets cuz has a nice pawn yeah
I I see what I see your point but I
don't I don't know it's a bit more than
a pawn still because it can be freed up
maybe maybe I should have tried to
prepare a for instead of what I did
that sets possible okay so now I'm
threatening to take on g2 which is quite
obvious admittedly but well you can try
okay so I can take this or what's what
is the defense ninety-three no boom
any thoughts on the world rapid and
blitz white resigns yeah that wasn't
very subtle threat but it worked
yeah King takes Queen Adriatic f2 any
thoughts on the world rapid and blitz
happening in Saudi Arabia a lot of
players seem to be protesting it yeah I
am I allowed to make political
statements it's a little bit tricky
effort as long as it's small about
Donald Trump
I might be able to say something well
people protest against those things but
I mean they still play at the end this
is a thing yeah I mean they had the
Women's World Championship in Iran and I
mean at the end they they played most of
the women played I mean there were some
protests but actually boycotting it was
really rare so if people don't like it
yeah they should simply not not go and
we'll see if that happens on the part of
Vida I don't I don't quite understand is
it really the case that there are no one
and that there are no other countries
applying for those events is it really
that it has to be dictatorships and and
other other questionable countries all
the time I don't I don't know I really
don't know I mean is it really the case
that you don't get let's say in normal
countries supplying maybe this is really
this really is the case I think it's
really am a bit of a shame in someone's
in some way we have to wrap it and
blitzen berlin some time ago in 2015 and
i was really hoping to play there but
then the German Chess Federation for
some reason I made it like you needed
2500 to play so I wasn't
loud was crazy and then at the end
people that showed up at the event were
allowed to play basically no matter what
the rating was so that was extremely
strange anyway and let's see what's
going on here 95 he will attack this
yeah this I mean that's a wacky opening
that he played but it doesn't feel all
that terrible actually the position now
I mean it's not all that terrible so I
can take c7 here and I probably should
because it leaves black weirdly
coordinated I will go Knight a5 and
maybe just Bishop g2 where's good
I mean blacks players a little bit loose
if you want to want to call it like that
but it doesn't mean that I'm winning
automatically queen x3 well he will take
and then 95 if that really gives black
some some sort of compensation yeah it's
not a clear clear position drilling I
wonder if he four is a move to return
the porn
it looks again quite loose but I have to
click quickly he can take of course but
I felt like returning stuff is not a bad
idea also every five incoming
so if I've what is he going to do 94
maybe something like that this is also
hanging let me take this position is
probably just winning for white but I
mean it split seven so this and you will
take a 1 I can check you there but that
doesn't really work so if I just Castle
yeah maybe
he has no real way to save the night
anyhow it should be seven the screen a
jade and but with castles I'm at least
developing somewhat at five and Bishop
g5 is certainly good to play him as an
idea at least now he's thinking a little
bit and not playing instant moves all
the time I mean he clearly decided early
on that he just wants to play something
wacky and irritate me and so it gives
that up okay I kind of have to take it
okay and now I'm sitting in that
diagonal I would like to like to check a
little bit myself and not just defend
here I mean I think he cannot yeah I
want to at least prevent him from being
on the g8 die and on the G file which
worked yeah it's there anything active
that I can play instead of moving the
rook property not so let's move the rook
okay so I think if v if v looks right
yeah being active and now here and then
nighty for next night before to take on
c5 it would be nice
94 I can take but doesn't really do much
you can take on f1 but I take c5 chicks
chicks I don't know I am on 30 something
seconds yeah yeah so he swindled me am
that's all is that always sucks yeah
someone playing complete nonsense and
then you lose the threat but talking
anyway it happens and it happened a lot
against this player in I usually have
winning positions and then you find some
some tactic okay anyhow anyhow probably
I was talking too much at the beginning
okay so let's have a new game going and
it was kind of tricky at the bed the
first yeah I mean here somewhere or in
the Blitz game and that's probably
playable but I just spent far too much
time so we have from Peck see here
playing with white and what are we going
to do let's try something else I want I
wanted to try test the perk defense and
now we get into some sort of Sicilian
[Music]
okay he tries for the big clamp as it is
caught
yeah I'm not really I don't really know
what this stuff
what's that question about an endgame
book yeah I didn't I didn't see it I
have to say I'm sorry I was looking at
the game the game before that and not
really seeing the question so if you if
you would repeat it it would be nice I'm
happy to try to answer okay I should
really not blunder this this kind of
things okay very strange
okay it it's not so easy but I already
should not blunder things like this
I think you should probably well there
was a question what endgame poking
turetsky zenkei manual or fundamental
chess endings I don't know if do you
really need fundamental chess endings I
think for the four fundamental said you
might as well use the 100 end games book
and for more complicated stuff the
endgame manual I don't think you need
need much more I think you only need
those two ended game books of course
there's tons more and if you want to do
something else yeah you can get caution
always book book on route endings for
example it's an interesting book of
course but in general I think the the
usual suspects and the endgame manual
and the 100 end games is totally
sufficient I don't think you really need
much more ok so here I'm a pawn down but
I can always claim some compensation
with the bishop pair even if it's not
warranted you can always say I have got
the bishop pair so it's kind of yeah
maybe it is enough
maybe not probably not but maybe it is
actually
maybe it is his rukon a3 is kind of
weird and I have quite active collisions
I don't want to check on on b5 really
maybe I go back and go 86 or something
or the night only 7 is not a good piece
maybe I should activate it but I don't
really know where and how
maybe yeah I know it's really really not
easy
yeah I would go for the turetsky one if
you don't have it I mean it's kind of
even if it is too even if it is a bit
too sophisticated in some cases it's so
kind of the book yeah it's always good
to have me simply sometimes to look
things up or make sure about some things
if you don't really know exactly if
something is correct or not
I don't know and coach Choi's book I
mean I have it in German language and it
was I think originally released in
German but there should be translations
there's just one book per caution on
loop ending so it's it's that's it like
the caution of book there is only this
book as far as I know and again I have
the German the German language version
and I'm not aware of something else
existing but I mean there should be an
English version would be weird if they
have not translated that it's a couple
of years old of is them so it probably
will have the odd term will have the
will have the odd imprecision do - yeah
simply engines not being used that much
but it's still on so very good good
stuff so I'm still there porn down
and try to try to prove some sort of
compensation probably I don't have any
yeah but after regroup Yemen and the
night does not have fantastic squares no
83 no d6 I mean a 3 but ok that's not a
really great square Jojo
I'm not really sure if a six is a move
for me or not
96
maybe maybe 96 is actually a move for
him but be to Hanks so not straightaway
him yeah this is this is an interesting
interesting choice I have I have 85
after which she has to take so his pawn
structure will be weakened a lot
Rubenstein's and games were excellent
yeah but you cannot really say it's
perfect or anything I mean this is like
100 years ago and obviously today they
are stronger but it was still very good
and especially considering that in that
time the defense wasn't all that great
that often makes excellent study
material ok I did not really see that he
attacks this so I have to do something
for him it takes the eight twenty seven
eight he only has he only has Bishop a6
which is not all that clear if this is
great his knight simply has no squares
so at least that was my idea
trapping this when Bishop is six I go be
three that was my was my point okay
hmm how does he keep it I don't see how
he keeps it maybe he just wants to win
on time which is a good strategy I am
down at time quite a lot
can take you four actually
now this we will definitely win on time
hey what a joke that that silly queen
have six one in the game yeah okay that
is just what happens okay
so yo let's go for the next game
yeah I know we still have to put up with
non increment chance here I mean the use
you see how silly it is if you see the
st. Louis tournament at the moment this
is a completely idiotic way of playing
chess nowadays see the game Westley so
against to me guess iam
crazy okay gracias por nada okay did I
play him last week
ya think yeah I think I played him last
week yeah I think he plays the same
stuff with white yeah
if I am correct I'm not mistaken
what would be the squad car don't play
with red ruin stand in a world match I
don't know you know a disease are always
weird things to to think about him you
know in a purely time-machine situation
I mean it would be a very clear win of
course for cars but I mean they they
they were they were extremely well
talented players back back in the day so
they would catch up quite quite quickly
with with modern with modern play so I'm
keeping this covered yeah black tries to
maybe exchange this bishop with Queen b6
and things like that nice quick is quick
under on the C foul
it's probably just about equal
disposition
no just equal
this ending is not much not much but you
can play it of course and claim that you
have the slightly more active pieces and
a slightly better structure maybe you
can claim that I will try I will try
gain some space 97 probably I don't
think I can take a seven no echoes them
okay how Italy is out of the
championships that's that's crazy right
yeah it wasn't that wasn't an easy match
Sweden is is not it not an easy opponent
but of course you can always say hey
they should have done it in the regular
in the regular group I'm not really
well-informed I don't know what
opponents they had in there in there in
the regular group
I mean for example Germany had a fairly
simple group to qualify in I think I
mean we have we had absolutely no
problem to do it yeah while talking
about Italy in football I'm trying to
squeeze water out of stone here I mean
I'm a bit better here but tough to break
down black
I think it just has to go back to 2cn
we should be 5 I take d6 that should be
excellent for white 95 I just take the
night probably and play with night
against Bishop anticipation we'll never
take any of my pawns I think this is
best so now my idea was to head towards
G form
yeah he wants to put the bishop on b5
which which he will probably manage
bishop and then I'm going back you know
okay
yeah cause is really a fantastic blitz
player it's just astounding he is
probably completely dominating ding in
the Blitz him I did not didn't see
anything of course didn't because I was
working this evening so let's go here
so I see it's age six on the agenda
probably it is I can't I have to do this
anyway I guess with this one
hmm if I take
I don't really see any progress if I
drink yeah
some tries to go to e7 to f5 or where is
he going will seem
I had will be probably difficult to to
make any serious headway my bill my
night has has no squares is the thing
there's no squares to go to if I go be
five he has to go back with the bishop I
mean like there to e8 it looks extremely
off forward from the difficult difficult
to do much against it yeah maybe I
should have taken maybe I should have
taken no on on age five
let's see what happens now time is not
great
I can probably not take this
it's probably just a draw this position
it's a bit of a shame because of Blake's
extremely passive play but you can maybe
not win it I have absolutely no time on
the clock
Isis I mean this is absolutely terrible
position and now this is actually
marching I have no time he will win this
game after playing extremely passive
moves the whole game but again just a
bit too slow today which is not entirely
entirely unusual yeah I had for a long
time I don't know that was just like
that was just too slow yeah I mean the
whole game Meganium was pretty pretty
straightforward but I don't plan too
slowly
so yeah the rapid end blitz World
Championships being in Saudi Arabia I
don't know did players already say that
they wouldn't play or so somebody in
particular I did not really am follow
the subject they're only they only
announced that some some days ago
I know that our music shock will not
play I I read that she said that she's
said that she said that she wouldn't
play and she cannot she said that she
cannot defend her two titles so in the
meantime I started the game against TM
killed young Hollywood de Moura and we
have the Scotch four nights on the board
so let's see he's trying to that's wrong
he's not trying to play actively he does
play actively so I mean yeah rupee one
maybe is that a good idea
you know see for I have 93 on idea for
so I've got some square for the bishop
huh it still plays it I'm a little bit
surprised that he does so I mean I'm not
saying that I have something fantastic
I'm still I'm still surprised okay let's
do this Quincy three edges sacrifice and
I go Bishop f5 next
I don't know isn't that the weakened
reconstruction whom
mmm okay I've knowed f5 it's not really
really that great but it just can't just
go here that's not bad
white has a very sound porn structure
yeah I might even consider to simply
drop back and say that this is a great
pose a great great position for the
bishop no that's not bad
rook a one next yep
I think I'm slightly better in this
position at least slightly better maybe
even more but I'm very slow today not
really no I didn't really have such a I
mean I have no excuse and I mean I had a
typical normal to put me a typical
workday let's say and nothing nothing
terrible so I will be tired but nothing
out of the ordinary so yeah I'm thinking
about Knight to f5 if this is the move
really not sure about it night at 5:09
h5e
stephen is suggesting this in the chat
definitely possible moves and he's
trying to go a form that's quite
understandable
yeah it's a good question if Irish white
sauce what is more what is harder doing
eight hours of chess lessons or eight
hours in IT controlling what I did
before doing chest teaching full-time
and the eight hours of lessons is
definitely it's definitely harder
because in the eight hours if you really
do like eight hours of lessons full
eight hours you just have to you have no
moments of relaxation if you do one hour
of a chess lesson you're basically
thinking the whole time and you're
asking questions
checking answers yeah you have no quiet
moment in some way and in in the typical
office environment you have those
moments simply where you again they
won't do all that much greeting
something or you just don't do anything
for a couple of minutes and this is
difficult in a lesson at least the way I
do the lessons I usually do stuff so um
this is all nice and good but probably
with a four is going to
yeah defenders yeah quite quite easily
why do I have any chance to do stuff I
can I go Here I am it it's probably not
not much
I mean it is not much yeah what I was
thinking is maybe he will take on e4 I
guess like here then this controlling f4
but I can try h4 h5 but it's still of
course nothing I mean okay you can also
never do this but it's probably just
equal yeah that's true an office you can
be lazy for 10 minutes and nobody
notices here but it's a little bit
difficult if you are in a chess lesson
yep it's not much if anything but you
can try you can try any way of provoking
some sort of weakness oh wow
going for fancy stuff so I can take here
is a bit down one time you can take here
give a check-cashing occasion because at
least you can work in your underwear hmm
not sure it would feel weird to work in
my underwear I mean you can definitely
in the summer you can wear shorts which
is which is nice
I can I can just winner on timeless
positioning of course by taking well
let's say continue this position yeah I
would definitely become a teacher again
yeah that's it's really it's a really
great job
yeah I can offer a draw I'm not really
the kind of person who places on it's
it's really a little bit ridiculous so
let's go one more game
one more game is in autumn I didn't I
don't know why I really lost quite a bit
today alright what did i do today I was
not a good school yeah I wonder first
year and then then lost them
many corner that who is that
Mika Catalan he's got a high rating I
usually its rating is lower to five
something
[Music]
okay NAT D 3 D 3 way slower build up
okay I want to go with g 6 m 9 2 z 300k
and 95 what's the point Jim
yeah maybe I could have tried a little
bit more in that game eh you're right as
a remark by Stephen that I probably did
not try the hardest in the game against
them Killian
that's may be true am probably could
have said them more problems so um yeah
why does what is why doing here
not much I wonder if this is a move or
not be good women I'm always a little
bit uncertain yeah those Knights III
setups tend to they tend to be a little
bit beyond me maybe this is not good
so I'm basically claiming that this
bishop on this bishop is not good but he
tries to tries to regroup at 97 no gyf
94 it's not a big deal it's at least I
think it is
yeah you cannot bet on chess games I
think online that and I think it makes
some sense here because collusion and in
chess games are so easy to accomplish so
no no betting site would probably be
willing to to to go for this okay so
what's going on here yeah but beef beef
is before such a problem I can take all
97 I've got the a file so trying to
trade the f3 Knight and before I take
her back to the seventh um okay so he
basically says okay f5f moka5 is
ridiculous so yeah a phone I didn't like
because of Bishop before that probably
just loses the important in the long run
I was here for perhaps d4 I mean T phone
and then mail maybe maybe it's not such
a big deal at age five hangs you know
okay didn't he didn't think about it I
know what I think it seems at least I
came just thinking about Bishop h6
yeah you could bet on the yeah that's
true him the the cards match last year
you could bet on but so okay it's be
five and move trying to undermine it
here probably not five hmm I'm a bit too
slow he and making a decision this is
again trying to prepare Bishop h6
tickets back here okay
[Music]
I'm just I'm just too slow here what
what what what deck am i doing
[Music]
surprised that you take that he took I'm
thinking 95 okay
hmm I get them again Maya again a square
here I wonder if we're looking something
fundamental like f4 so I don't know I
think this looks kind of okay
[Music]
so I can take one when on g6 after
goodnight see form okay
that's bad
okay you might just crush me here but 96
Queen h4 isn't clear not at all clear
right if a teen night f3 is a movie but
he has got King edge one unfortunately
I think I think I probably have to
recapture then I'll do something crazy
tonight have three and then Queen g3
okay just just that I can still play
that maybe not Natchez reenacting tag
tag tag mm-hmm that's not clear but I
can take their threat Queen f6 maybe
it's not as long as my queen is here I
have no time
what am i doing you know I'm just
playing extremely slowly I'm just
playing far too slowly him maybe Queen
evade doesn't even work now now probably
just Knight f5 maybe I can go Knight f5
if he takes then I cannot take I have 9
seconds though now I don't know very
very slow accession
Jim and now what No
Wow he blunders made what a lucky break
what a lucky break now I got completely
outplayed him our final final trick
let's aim huh there was a tough position
I really don't know what to make out of
this is how bad this actually is I don't
I don't I didn't like my position it was
really not that great I always I always
struggle with those 93 setups and I
really don't know how to handle them
probably I think ok I hope you enjoyed
the session I think I'm I'll be back
next week the same time same place and
hope to be a little bit quicker in this
in this in this upcoming session yeah
thanks a lot I'll be back next week bye
bye
you